good morning John it's Friday it's
question Tuesday the day that we answer
real questions from you lured fighters
why do you always get to do question
videos - because you do videos on
Tuesdays not fair I went to Twitter I
got questions here they are numbers real
or did we make them up I feel like we
started out hard question videos are
supposed to be easier Hey okay next
question what's the best book you've
read lately yeah I often don't like to
promote books by dead people because
there are so many great books being
written by people who are working right
now but the actual answer to this
question is dawn by Octavia Butler out
of the xenogenesis trilogy and it is
somewhat timely because it's being
turned into a TV series by ava duvernay
and this is shockingly the first time in
Octavia Butler work is being adapted for
TV or movies ever
how did that happen anyway dawn is very
good and it gives enormous insight into
what it is like to be a human and also
what human means which is yeah how is
book editing going you know not great
it's been a busy week I have a deadline
that I may miss but I'm working on it
it's a lot of stress in my life right
now what is our official emoji / emoji
combination for your new book Hank well
I don't know so let's ask people to come
up with stuff so we'll come back to that
at the end of the video my book is
called an absolutely remarkable thing
it's available for pre-order now and it
will come out on September 25th how do I
stay informed of current events without
having them take over my life and stress
me out if you figure that one out
I I think that all of us would really
like to know your answer what was the
first thing you did after you finished
writing your first book i sat and
watched a French guy play his accordion
in the airport while his little French
children ran around and were silly and
thought about how a lot of weird things
happen in my book but also a lot of
weird things happen in the real world
and then I got on a plane and I went
home I think that was pas
I was going home from pod con which is
interesting because the next question
what is this adorable rainbow I saw
under the plane wing on the flight home
from pod con that's called a glory and
it's very similar to a rainbow in that
it's an effect of the diffraction of
light when it hits water droplets the
glory happens with smaller droplets of
water than a rainbow and you have to be
between the Sun and the cloud in order
for
for you to see a glory which means you
don't usually see one when you're on the
ground
it can't happen though and so glories
were seen before planes happened mostly
from people who are on the tops of
mountains which is really cool and also
those people were often inside of the
cloud so there was fog and so in
addition to the glory you get what's
called a Brock inspector which is very
cool and a super creepy thing that
you're seeing right now right creepy
can you sing your last text message good
[Music]
yes I could record that cast on Monday
and happy birthday Julie thanks Marianne
for keeping my life in order if you
could wear any Elton John outfit which
one would it be
I don't know we I guess we have to go
look it out and John outfits now how big
is he five eight feedback no errors just
give general feedback this is helpful
thanks Google I mean it said if I could
so if I could I don't know Elton John
outfits um that one's real good with
like beetlejuice but the sparkly banana
I think it would be real hard to see
with this one I got now I want to do an
Elton John outfit review podcast I
definitely cannot compete with the chest
hair I play piano and also am a piano
yeah I think I'm gonna go with sparkly
banana Beetlejuice and actually that
reminds me it's time to look up our
emoji sequence Katherine says that she
has one but it has spoilers so that's
the advantage of being Katherine and
also April May says robot dark haired
white girl Statue of Liberty burrito and
you know feel like she knows what she's
talking about John I'll see you on
Tuesday